[Musik]
sie sind groß bizarr an farbe und form
ein bisschen unheimlich und unfassbar
faszinierend zumindest für sehr viele
leute herzlich willkommen zur
sternstunde philosophie die uns heute in
die urzeit führt ich möchte herausfinden
warum wir uns für die ausgestorbenen
dinosaurier interessieren
und was sie uns sagen über die frage ob
auch wir nur eine episode sind
ich freue mich dabei jetzt mit einem der
renommiertesten dinosaurier forscher
unserer zeit zu sprechen nämlich mit dem
paläontologen die studie von der
universität edinburgh herzlich
willkommen
ja wenn wir über dinosaurier sprechen
dann behelfen wir uns oft mit solchen
modellen wir stellen uns die dinosaurier
auf eine bestimmte art und weise vor
und sie sagen sie auch machen wir uns
falsche bilder zum beispiel haben viele
dinge offenbar federn
aber manchmal haben wir lieber wenn die
dinosaurier so bleiben wie sie sind also
zb in jurassic park hat steven spielberg
auch gesagt er wisse schon dass gewisse
dinge nicht stimmen
aber wenn man ihnen federn aufgesetzt
hätte dann hätten sie weniger
furchterregend aus gesehen deswegen sind
die dinosaurier in jurassic park alle
nackt
es gibt einen ein solches verziehen dass
sie auch gefunden haben nämlich dieses
hier für mich war interessant dass sich
die federn in diesem fossil erst gar
nicht gesehen haben es sind nämlich
nicht diese dinger hier in der mitte das
sind die regionen dieses dinosaurier
sondern außen rum diese schatten
jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt ein bauer
hat das gefunden dieses fossil das zeigt
auch wie unglaublich zufällig diese
funde sind wie muss ich mir das
vorstellen wenn sie ins feld gehen wie
wissen sie eigentlich wie sie überhaupt
zu graben beginnen sollen
das ja einfach alles mit erde bedeckt
dh ich würde das auch erkennen also ich
meine wenn ich jetzt so etwas finden
würde ja aber dinosaurier knochen da
würde ich wahrscheinlich einfach denken
und stein
wenn wir darüber sprechen was wir uns
für bilder machen von den dinosauriern
gibt es auch manchmal den vorwurf ist
dass sie einen dinosaurier rassismus
nämlich dass in all den filmen immer die
gleichen dinosaurier auftauchen die
typischerweise in nordamerika gefunden
worden sei
und da wir die neuen art sind die man in
afrika entdeckt oder in indien oder in
china kommen überhaupt nicht voraus
filmstars nehmen sie das bestätigen
[Musik]
wie ist das eigentlich wenn ich so ein
fossil finde gehört mir das dann
[Musik]
und ich wollte vorher noch wissen die
fossilien eigentlich gehören die
gefunden werden
also ist dieser pharma zum beispiel
jetzt vermögen weil er dieses großartige
tier entdeckt hat
jetzt haben sie vorher eine art
werbesport für die paläontologie
abgegeben wie wichtig diese disziplin
ist solche unsere wurzeln verstehen das
sind ja nicht die wurzeln der
aber die evolutionsgeschichte immer
weiter aufdröseln trotzdem ist es so
dass zb in deutschland die professorin
für paläontologie immer weniger werden
die disziplinen gilt als auch ideen fach
sie ist unter beschuss man fragt sich
wozu eigentlich
was antworten sie wieso brauchen die
japanologin mal abgesehen davon dass es
für sie viel spaß bedeutet über den
zusammenhang zwischen evolution
paläontologie und klimawissenschaften
sprechen wir nachher gleich noch würde
gerne noch einmal auch bei der
faszination dieser tiere bleiben
dieses dino fieber ist das eigentlich
weltumspannend sie haben der
ausgrabungen gemacht in litauen in rom
in china sind alle menschen
gleichermaßen fasziniert oder gibt es
auch keine ahnung länder wo sie denken
das interessiert keinen zu sein ist
etwas was nicht fasziniert ist die
schiere größe dieser tiere also wenn man
sich das mal vorstellen dass ein solches
tier und umständen 100 tonnen schwer
sein konnte
unter umständen 1,8 millionen mal
schwerer als ich wenn man sie einfach
mal vorstellt das ist unfassbar groß und
schwer
1500 kilogramm kot pro tag also eine
unfassbare menge
wir sehen hier auch eine grafik um die
seen eine frau links am bildrand im
verhältnis zu diesen dinosaurier ist es
nicht also ich würde sagen
wahrscheinlich ein teil der faszination
hängt auch mit der größe zusammen oder
[Musik]
und wachsen die oder wuchsen die
schneller als menschen oder lebten die
so lange dass die so gross werden konnte
nur pflanzen vielleicht sollten wir mehr
essen sie auch so
leider nur so aber warum weiß man etwas
darüber warum die so sehr in die höhe
schossen
so groß wurden
so faszinierend wenn ich ihnen zuhöre zu
merken es ist eine kombination zwischen
dinge finden theorien aufstellen sich
wieder annähern
dann hat man vielleicht eine theorie und
irgendwann die hartz iv sie ziert weil
man etwas neues heraus findet mir fällt
in diesem zusammenhang das
riesenfaultier maggie 1
dieses riesenfaultier das ist ein
prähistorisches tier dass stand bis vor
noch nicht allzu langer zeit im
zoologischen museum in zürich und war
der liebling aller kinder und saß man
dieses tier restaurieren musste weil die
kinder sich damit klebrigen schokolade
händchen daran geklammert hatten das
fellbacher filz hat man gesagt wir
betrachten die neueren studien und es
war völlig klar dieses tier hat sony
ausgesehen das hatte kein fällen
das hat er auch nicht ein niedliches
gesicht sondern es war wahrscheinlich so
aus und so hätte es aber keiner gemacht
das heißt man verifizieren dann theorien
ideen wie etwas aus gesehen habt gibt es
etwas wovon sich selbst jetzt schon im
laufe ihrer karriere
enttäuscht einsehen mussten dass hat
nicht gestimmt haben jetzt total geehrt
[Musik]
wir sehen also es gibt ganz viele
theorien über die dinosaurier die man
weiter erforschen wird uns irgendwann
findet man wieder neue sachen heraus
etwas ist aber klar die dinosaurier in
dieser art und weise gibt es nicht mehr
die sind ausgestorben
vor 66 millionen jahren und zwar gibt es
die sogenannte impact theorie die besagt
dass ein meteorit oder ein aus theorie
de in den golf von mexiko geknallt ist
vor 66 millionen jahren es gibt eine bbc
dokumentation die versucht dieses
ereignis noch einmal darzustellen wir
schauen uns das kurz anbieten
für 66 millionen jahren schlug ein
meteorit mit einem durchmesser von rund
zehn kilometern größe bei der yucatan
halbinsel im golf von mexiko auf die
erde ein
so entstand der 180 kilometer große
chicxulub krater
riesige erdbeben tsunamis gigantische
staub wellen erschütterten infolge des
einschlags den gesamten planeten und
verbreiteten sich um die welt der
meteoriteneinschlag dies wahrscheinlich
auch den riesigen decken vulkan in
indien explodieren
dieses schleuderte nochmals zwei
millionen kubikkilometer basalt in die
atmosphäre
die totale apokalypse das ende der
dinosaurier
[Musik]
sie beschreiben das in ihrem buch
aufstieg und fall der dinosaurier das
ist ein buch das die geschichte noch
einmal der dinosaurier erzählt und in
den
usa und in großbritannien zu einem
bestseller avanciert ist und in diesem
buch beschreiben sie das so plastisch
dass man richtig mit leidet mit dieser
dinosaurier familie die betroffen ist
wobei sie natürlich nicht diese familie
die sie beschreiben ist nicht unterhalb
des meteoriten sofort ausgelöst sondern
es kommen nach und nach immer mehr
wählen sozusagen die die die die die
erde bebt es gibt die vulkane es gibt
zunahme ist die atmosphäre verdunkelt
sich man denke zwischen eigentlich
hätten sie auch roman autor werden
können und das ist interessant es
geschah sehr schnell 10.000 jahre für
einen politologen ist das schnell für
mich ist natürlich unglaublich lang auch
wenn dir die menschheitsgeschichte
anschauen
vielleicht kann ja mal einem zeitstrahl
sehen die die dinosaurier sich
entwickelt haben also wir sehen vor 235
millionen jahren ungefähr haben sie
begonnen sich zu entwickeln 66 millionen
jahre kam dann dieses dieser einschlag
und wir sehen auf der letzten meile der
geschichte des planeten
sieht man da noch den menschen kurz
darauf marschieren
also das heißt die zeiträume sind enorm
wie lange die dinosaurier gelebt haben
das ist enorm
glauben sie eigentlich der mensch könnte
auch so ein dauerbrenner werden und so
ist es ja tatsächlich dass ganz viele
leute jetzt sagen wir sind am abgrund
der menschheit wir sind kurz davor ist
ganz zu verlassen und dann werden wir
nur diese mini episode sein für die sich
eigentlich gar niemanden interessiert
würden sie sagen der mensch ist schlecht
für den planeten
das massensterben war damals
[Musik]
genau und sie haben jetzt mehrere male
betont dass die geschwindigkeit mit der
diese veränderung vor sich geht eine
ganz andere ist weil ihr vor immer in
diesen unglaublichen zeithorizonten
gesprochen haben aber trotzdem ist es so
wie sich jetzt auch betont haben sie
haben das vierte massensterben erwähnt
das war das vierte in der geschichte der
der des planeten
es gab das fünfte massensterben mit dem
aussterben der dinosaurier und nun gibt
es viele die sagen wir stehen kurz davor
ein sechstes massensterben zu erleben zb
eberhard brandes der chef von wwf
deutschland der sagt wir sind kurz davor
so viel biodiversität zu vernichten wie
es eigentlich seit der zeit der
dinosaurier nicht mehr der fall war
jetzt sagen sie die geschwindigkeit ist
der unterschied macht es für sie auch
ein unterschied dass wir menschen das
verursachen oder würden sie sagen na ja
auch der mensch mit seinen zielen und
zwecken ist ja teil der erde das ist
auch irgendwie natur
er gibt uns das eine verantwortung die
sichtweise eines politologen auf den
klimawandel finde ich auch deswegen so
interessant weil man ja auch sich
vorstellen könnte dass sie sagen naja
die dinosaurier die haben
so erhalten weil es das vierte
massensterben gab die sind sozusagen
nachdem hier löste war auf diesem
planeten sind die in diesem moment
konnten die sich entwickeln und
vielleicht können wir uns vorstellen
auch wenn der mensch mal vorbei ist wann
kommt etwas neues ist dieser blickwinkel
des paläontologen auch zulässig
darüber nicht sprechen sonst hören die
leute auf klimaschutz zu betreiben
ich würde gerne mit ihnen noch über
tausend sachen sprechen aber ganz kurz
vielleicht noch einmal zurück zu dieser
impact theorie ich sitze hier ja auch
als journalistin und muss die
verschiedenen theorien im blick haben
und es ist ja nicht so dass es nicht
einen streit darüber geben was genau zu
diesem aussterben geführt hat es gibt
neben der impact theorie die von canis
muss theorie und da gibt es eine
schweizerin die sehr prominent ist gerta
keller die eben sagt nein nein das war
nicht so sondern die lehrt an der
universität princeton und die sagt im
decker und trat in indien da haben die
schikane begonnen vor sich hin zu
spielen das hat schon zu einer
veränderung der atmosphäre geführt und
natürlich gab es diesen einschlag des
meteoriten aber letztendlich ist die
abfolge sozusagen auch leicht anders
gelesen ich will gar nicht mit ihm
darüber streiten welche theorie stimmt
weil ich habe auch nichts dazu
beizutragen
mich interessiert etwas anderes nämlich
die tatsache dass 2010 ganz viele
wissenschaftler von der ganzen welt in
seien sind der großen zeitschrift
eine art manifest veröffentlicht haben
gesagt haben der streit ist beigelegt
wir sind hier für die impact theorie
können wissenschaftler via
mehrheitsvotum einen solchen streit
abbrechen
[Musik]
diese erklärung so lustige dinge die so
lange her sind und trotzdem ist diese
wissenschaft so dynamisch das ist
wirklich faszinierend etwas was auch
ganz viele leute interessiert mich auch
ist ob diese dinosaurier je zurückkehren
werden
das ist ja die geschichte die ganz viele
hollywood filme erzählen viele science
fiction filme erzählen und wenn wir an
jurassic park denken da geht es dann
natürlich 1990 um den roman damals von
mike ritscher der die vorlage
geschrieben hat jurassic park als roman
vorlage für den film und in diesem film
ist tatsächlich so dass die dinosaurier
zurückkehren
nun gibt es einen wissenschaftlichen
berater dieses filmes der ist auch
paläontologe und das ist ja klar und
jack warner überlegte ich tatsächlich
nicht wie wir jetzt wie im film eben wie
eine dna kreieren können aber wie wir
das huhn so verändern können dass daraus
ein mini dinosaurier
ganz kurz zu
oder ein huhn hausse ist es eine gute
idee können wir vielleicht ganz kurz
erzählen dies ist bei jurassic park das
ist ja so dass es um mücken geht die
dinosaurier gestochen haben das blut
raus gezogen haben und die sind
konserviert in bernstein so erzählt es
der roman und der film und aus diesen
mücken wird dann die dna entnommen also
das ist nicht funktionsfähig nicht
passieren
unmöglich
ist aber auch ein bisschen spielen
ich würde gerne noch einmal auf die
kritik auch zurückkommen war in jurassic
park ist ja schon so bereits im roman
angelegt dass das auch eine art technik
kritische stimme davor kommt das ist
eine kapitalismuskritische geschichte
auch weil menschen einen vergnügungspark
machen mit dinosauriern und sehr viel
geld damit verdienen und das ganze gerät
außer kontrolle zum beispiel versuchen
die dinosaurier so herzustellen dass sie
sich nicht vermehren können das geht
schief dann fällt elektrizität aus die
tiere brächen aus und das ganze gibt
einen riesen durcheinander an die saß
der menschen sterben und so weiter
denken sie auch dass bei so einem who
knows august die sache außer kontrolle
geraten könnte und wenn nein warum nicht
[Musik]
eine ganz kurze frage und die antwort
zum schluss noch verraten sie uns nach
ihrem lieblingsteam ganz herzlichen dank
[Musik]